we must in fact ensure our little  process will not be used again to try to  discredit American democracy this is  about they're still engaged I know I'm  not asking you to agree I know but you  all know that Russia and others now are  engaged in cyber attacks to try to  fundamentally alter our electoral  process our whole focus should be if I  were in the United States Senate bill  I'd be talking about what do we do to  ensure the security of our electoral  process how do we get the paper bounced  what should the federal government be  doing to all the states because it cost  a lot of money we should be saying what  do you need here's what we're gonna do  so for a federal election you must have  the following criteria man and if you do  that then in fact they'll do it for the  state elections too so it's all about  the corruption of our system and  initially go ahead sir don't pay  attention thank you  I didn't mean it that way  you